Den transparensen är någonting som vi väldigt gärna vill inspirera vår bransch till.
När du köper en hudborgsprodukt eller en annan konsistensmetisk produkt så har du faktiskt ingen aning om oftast när den tillverkades.
Den kan ju ha stått på ett lager två år innan den hamnar hemma hos dig.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga sura kollegor, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Lydia Engholm från...
Är det Skinom eller Skin-om, Skin-om, Skin...
Hur säger ni er att företags namn?
Vi brukar vara vänliga och säga att man får uttala det hur man vill, men vi kallar det för Skinom och det är ju en förkortning, eller en hopslagning egentligen av två ord, skin och microbiom.
Ja okej, det var en...
Ja, jag förstår, du tappar mig redan i liksom första, första startmeningen.
Vad betyder microbiom?
Microbiom betyder microbiom, och microbiomet, vi pratar ju då om hudens microbiom.
Du har ju även ett microbiom i magetarm till exempel, men när vi pratar om hudens microbiom så pratar vi om alla de mikroorganismer, svampar, bakterier, virus, som helt enkelt lever i symbios med oss på vår hud och som har ganska nya studier visat sig vara helt avgörande för vår hudhälsa.
Jag förstår, är du liksom kemist i bakgrunden eller är du en vd?
Vad är din roll, vad är din personlighetstyp?
Jag är inte kemist och det har vi förträffliga sådana i teamet.
Däremot så har jag jobbat innan jag då började på Skin om nästan tio år i skönhetsbranschen på ett svenskt kosmetika bolag.
Men förutom det så har jag en väldigt blandad bakgrund.
Jag har jobbat både som investment manager och jag har också jobbat som management consult på Business Sweden i två omgångar.
Normalt brukar jag stämma av mot min fru hur bra ett företag är.
När jag sa att jag skulle intervjua er eller dig då, så sa du också att du skulle skicka ett testprov på er produkt och då skrev jag det till Isla, min fru då.
Då skvar hon bara, ja!
Så då tolkar jag det som att ni är ett omtyckt företag.
Hon var inte lika exalterad när jag skulle intervjua gymgrossisten eller liknande, så nu är det positivt.
Vi har ju börjat bygga ett allt starkare varumärke här i Sverige, som såklart är vår hemmamarknad.
Nu vet jag inte om hon hade provat produkterna tidigare, men vi har ju väldigt nöjda kunder som gärna pratar om just produkten.
Jag tror att man också gillar oss för att vi utmanar.
Det är en bransch, vår bransch, som väldigt många nu börjar ifrågasätta, när det kommer till löften man ger och effekter man pratar om och så vidare.
Jag tänker att vi ska komma in lite mer på själva bolaget.
Du hoppade in ganska tidigt som vd i det här bolaget, när ni var relativt små.
Jag tycker att det är lite intressant varför man, alltså för bara tre år sedan, fyra år sedan omsatt en tre, tre och en halv miljon.
Nu har ni vuxit jättemycket och jättesnabbt, men varför lämnar man ett riktigt bra jobb till att hoppa på en sådan här grej?
Jag jobbade nästan tio år på ett svenskt stort kosmetiska bolag och var bland annat chef för produktutvecklingen där.
Så jag har jobbat väldigt mycket med produktutveckling just av kosmetiska produkter, hudvård bland annat.
Efter det har jag jobbat en hel del utomlands tidigare också, och bott i lite olika länder.
Så när jag lämnade det bolaget då flyttade jag till Kanada och jobbade som handelssekreterare för Business Sweden, alltså chef för Business Swedens organisation och team i Kanada.
Där blev jag för i tre och ett halvt år, bodde i Toronto.
Sen när jag flyttade hem och började fundera på vad jag ville göra, då fanns det en väldigt stark känsla att från att ha gått från ett stor bolag till att bygga ett mindre team.
Vi växte både omsättningen och teamet i Toronto, vi dubblade väl på tre år ungefär.
Och den känslan att bygga, skapa någonting och vara i en mindre kontext, kände jag var verkligen det jag ville fortsätta med.
Jag var inte sugen när vi flyttade hem på att gå in i ett storbolag igen, utan var väldigt sugen på att vara med och bidra till att bygga någonting från start.
Och då av en slump så träffade jag Johanna och Marcus som hade precis grundat företaget, som båda är tidigare kollegor till mig.
Så jag hade jobbat med båda under nästan tio år tidigare, så vi kände ju varandra.
Och då blev jag tillfrågad om jag ville ansluta som vd.
Och då var ju bolaget i sin linda.
Det fanns inga produkter.
Det var egentligen ett team på två personer.
Och jag kände väldigt starkt att visserligen så tar jag en risk i det här.
Och vi hade precis flyttat hem och två barn och så vidare.
Men när de förklarade vad visionen var med Skinom, att göra hudvård där man verkligen sätter hudens bästa först, utan kompromisser, så kände jag bara att jag måste vara med på det här.
Den stora insikten var väl också att, trots att jag hade jobbat med produktutveckling i tio år, så hade jag själv aldrig reflekterat egentligen på att en väldigt stor del av de ingredienser som man använder för att utveckla hudvårdsprodukter faktiskt inte är i produkten för hudens skull.
Utan det är ju för att produkten ska få en lång hållbarhet, vilket gör att man kan tillverka mycket större volymer och det blir ju ekonomiskt mycket bättre om man ser till företaget för att man får ju ner kostnaderna rejält.
Och Johanna pratade ju också om det här med hudens mikrobiom som vi pratade om i början.
Och det här var ju då ett ganska nytt forskningsområde som jag också kände var otroligt intressant.
Jag blev verkligen helt fascinerad över att jag själv inte hade koll på det här, jag hade ändå jobbat med det här.
Förståelsen då för att hudvårdskonsumenter absolut inte tänker på det här.
Och möjligheten då att vara med om att ta en sån här faktiskt otrolig innovation och göra det till en kommersiell produkt och bygga företaget kring det.
Det var otroligt lockande.
Så det var därför jag bestämde mig för att hoppa på.
Och sen hade jag väldigt stort förtroende såklart för de här grunderna eftersom jag kände dem sedan tidigare.
Men fanns det redan kapital i bolaget då?
Eller var det liksom bara en idé på den tiden?
Det fanns lite kapital.
Johanna Marcus hade hittat ett litet nätverk av Engel-investerare som hade stoppat in den första grundplåten i bolaget.
Men när jag började då, precis i början av 2020, så började vi direkt med att titta på att genomföra en till kapitalrunda för att vi behövde fylla på eftersom det hade också försenats.
Det har ju visat sig vara lättare sagt än att göra färsk huvudvård utan de här tillsatserna som man brukar ha i huvudvårdsprodukter vanligtvis.
Vi hade inga produkter över huvudvården över huvudvården och det här hade ju investerarna fått höra att vi ska lansera här och nu och så hade det blivit försenat flera gånger.
Så vi började förbereda för en kapitalrunda, men då kom ju pandemin.
Så det var bara att lägga den idén i byrålådan under ett tag.
Istället fick vi då, vi korttidspermitterade två personer i personalen.
Vi ska ner våra löner och så pratade vi med våra investerare och sa att nu ska vi sätta ett atum för när vi ska lansera våra första produkter.
Fram tills dess så visste vi att det inte var möjligt att ta in mer kapital.
För just i den perioden där våren 2020 så var det ju inga investerare som var beredda att satsa.
Och vi hade ju inte ännu bevisat oss.
Så det var väldigt mycket hårt arbete där under nio månader ungefär.
Men där tog vi fram våra två första produkter.
Och med då den säkerheten så kunde vi ju säga till våra investerare att vi kommer att öppna vår försäljning under hösten 2020.
Och då fick vi också förtroendet och vi kunde ta in lite mer kapital där i slutet av sommaren.
Ni bedriver er egna forskning men också er egna tillverkning.
Är det rätt uppfattat?
Nu förstår jag att du är vän med grundarna här, men är de liksom galna uppfinna jockar på ett kontor eller på ett labb som de vill testa och blanda grejer?
Du tycker det är kul med seerum och så får du hantera västen.
Eller är de business?
Alltså hur mycket av företaget är deras dröm av att göra en viss sorts produkt och hur mycket är hardcore-företagsamhet?
Jag ska säga att våra två grundare har ju också väldigt olika roller.
Marcus har ju aldrig varit operativt engagerad i bolaget, men han har ju varit en del av att också säkerställa att vi fick in investerare från start.
Johanna är ju hudforskare och har ju dedikerat hela sitt liv egentligen och sin karriär till att forska på huden.
Men hennes önskan om att göra hudvård, där vi bara tänker på vad huden behöver och mår bra av, den idén började växa under de tio år som hon jobbade i skönhetsbranschen också.
Hon hade tidigare jobbat med dermatologiskt och kliniskt.
Hon började känna till slut att jag använde inte själv de produkter jag är med och utvecklar och det känns inte bra i magen.
Men hon är ju ingen antipredör som hon brukar säga.
Hon har aldrig haft en dröm om att starta bolag, men den här känslan av att det jag är med och utveckla, det är ju inte det bästa för huden.
Och kopplat till hennes stora passion för just huden, som är ett av våra största organ, det gjorde att hon till slut då lämnade sin trygga anställning och startade Skinom.
Men hon är ju inte den här nutty professor som vi förstår att du är ut efter, men däremot så har vi väldigt kompletterande roller.
Hon är ju forskare och kan otroligt mycket om vår hud och är en av de ledande hudexperterna i världen på just hudens mikrobiom och så vidare.
Men hon är också medveten om vad jag har för styrkor och jag är medveten om hennes styrkor.
Så vi är ju ett väldigt bra kompletterande team.
Och att vi skulle fortsätta bedriva forskning från början, det var någonting också som våra investerare, vi talade om för dem från början att vi kommer behöva fortsätta forska samtidigt som vi utvecklar en kommersiell produkt i och med att vi behöver fortsätta lära oss så mycket om huden, det är så mycket vi fortfarande inte vet.
Och vi har ju en väldigt stark passion för att hjälpa våra kunder till bättre hudhälsa.
Och då behöver vi hela tiden också ligga i framkant forskningsmässigt.
Så vi har ett väldigt stark ben i forskning, men också i utveckling av våra produkter.
För att vi vet ju att de är de bästa just från ett hudhälsoperspektiv.
Hur funkar det med patent och liknande inom den världen?
Om du säger att ni lägger, för ni lägger ändå, nu kan inte jag exakt veta, för jag kan inte se så, men säg att ni har lagt 40 miljoner på att bygga bolagets produktportfölj och kunskap och IP och liknande.
Men man kan inte bara en person titta på burken och se att de har blandat det här.
Absolut, och det är ju...
På en ingredienslista ser du ju exakt vilka ingredienser som ingår i produkten.
Sen vet du ju inte kompositionen av koncentrationer till exempel.
Vi har ju, precis som du säger, vi har tagit in mer än 40 miljoner, ska jag säga, och det har ju gått till att just bygga vår R&D-avdelning och utveckla vår ändå lilla portfölj, skulle jag vilja säga.
Vi har ju ungefär 20 produkter i dag.
Vi hade ju under de första åren så satsade vi egentligen alla resurser och allt kapital just på R&D.
Vi hade vid ett tillfälle fyra heltidskemister under två år, för utan produkten så hade vi inte heller någonting att sälja och driva in hundar till vår hemsida och så vidare.
Så det har varit viktigt också för oss att titta på patentbiten.
Vi har två patentansökningar inlämnade.
Sen tar det ju minst två år ofta att få ett patent, men det har vi också gjort för att skydda.
Vi har tagit fram en väldigt specifikt teknologi för att se till att ingredienserna bibehåller sin effekt.
Och sen har vi också en patentansökning inne nu för granskning när det kommer till att vi har hittat ett sätt att själv konservera produkten.
Eftersom vi inte använder några konserveringsmedel så måste vi ändå säkerställa att det inte börjar växa svampar eller bakterier.
Och det tog många år att hitta just den här exakta kompositionen av ingredienser som både är bra för huden men som också konserverar produkten.
Vilka är investerarna som, för jag köper själva argumenten.
Nu är jag inte er typisk kund sådär och min första fråga som jag skickade till dig som vi inte har ställt den är vad behövs hudvård?
Men jag köper argumentet att torr hudvård eller vad jag ska kalla det, sådant som förvaras i rumstemperatur, man behöver blanda i saker som gör att det håller några år och då blir det ligga.
Jag fattar att det påverkar huden och det går in i huden och allt sådant där.
Men om man kommer till en investerare så säger man tja vi ska behöva 50 miljoner för att forska fram det här under fem år och lansera en portfölj.
Det krävs ju en viss sorts investerare som liksom går igång på den.
Den idén på något sätt.
Kan du berätta något om vilka investerarna var eller hur de liksom bemötte det här i frågor och vad...
Ni måste ändå ha målat upp någon sorts vision.
Jag tycker bara att det är en sådan här, ja absolut det där ser vi igen om femton år liksom.
Man måste ju nästan gå igång på produkten.
Ja och nej skulle jag vilja säga.
Vår första lilla grupp av ängelinvesterare det var en grupp personer som inte kunde någonting om hudvård och faktiskt alla utom en var män som inte själva var stor konsumenter på det här.
Men de trodde väldigt mycket på innovationen i det här och det var ju våra grundare och vi var väldigt bra på att förklara att det här är någonting helt unikt, det finns inget annat i världen.
Och vi kunde också bygga förtroende kring oss som team och de som grundare.
Johanna är som sagt en ledande hudforskare globalt sett.
Och jag tror att vi har varit bra också senare på vägen.
Att vi har ju fått in fler investerare på vägen.
Sen är ju alla som var med från början också fortfarande med.
Och har fortsatt att vara med i de olika rundor som vi har gjort.
För vi har tagit in kapital under flera tillfällen de sista fem åren.
Vi har haft investerare som faktiskt har kommit till oss och älskat produkten.
Och sagt att det här vill vi vara med på, vi tror på det här.
Så det har varit en väldigt spännande resa idag.
Så har vi ju drygt 20 delägare.
En som vi träffade som har varit väldigt viktig för oss är Karina Berg.
TV-personlighet.
Och vi träffades ju för nästan fem år sedan och började bara prata om ett samarbete.
Men hon trodde också så starkt på den här idén då hon själv hade varit väldigt hudvårdsintresserad men använt som väldigt många en rutin med över tio produkter.
Men hon började känna på något sätt att det här kan inte vara rätt.
Huden har ju varit med hos människor under hundratusentals år.
Behöver vi verkligen 14 steg en hudvårdsrutin?
Så för henne var det en väldigt stor insikt att den där magkänslan att det här är förmodligen bara marknadsföringsknep.
Det blev väldigt starkt för henne och hon kände då också att det här vill jag vara med på.
Så hon är ju också en delägare idag och en av våra större ambassadörer som har varit väldigt viktig för oss också att komma ut lite bredare.
Men vi har haft väldigt bra ägare som också har förstått att det tar tid, men sen har vi också kunnat visa på resultat ända från start egentligen.
Så har vi ju ändå byggt sakta men säkert och visat att vi kan också få det här att bli en kommersiell produkt som på sikt kommer bli bra för delägare också.
Så jävla sakta har det väl inte gått.
Om ni börjar på en, jag bara läser era siffror.
Om ni börjar på en miljon så gick det till tre och en halv, sen gick det till åtta och en halv, sen gick det till tjugo, sen gick det till trettio och nu när vi snackar här innan så...
För en av mina...
En sak som jag liksom fascineras av är hur man driver bolag med minusresultat.
Hur det kronlar med hur man tänker i budget.
Alltså det måste vara svårt att jobba mot underskott för det är inte lika logiskt som att jobba mot en nolla på något sätt.
Men då pratar du lite grann om hur det går.
Kan du inte bara fylla i oss lite hur det har gått här eller hur ni ser på 2025 och vad ni tror på?
Det har varit just att jobba med ett underskott.
Vi visste ju det från början att det skulle krävas stora investeringar i R&J för att ta fram våra produkter.
Det har krävt väldigt många timmar i vårt labb för att ta fram vår produktkortfölj.
Men vi har ju hela tiden också haft målsättningen att varje år krympa förlusten som vi har gjort.
Det är aldrig roligt att göra en förlust, men när den ändå är planerad så är det någonting som man lever med.
Då handlar det också om att hela tiden försöka växa intäkterna och så krympa den förlust vi har gjort.
Det har vi lyckats med varje år.
I år har planen varit att nu ska vi vända.
Vi har tillräckligt stor varumärkeskännedom och vi har produkter som tillgodoseer väldigt många olika typer av hudtillståndsbehov.
Målsättningen är ju i år att minst om det landar runt breakeven, vilket ju är ett stort kliv jämfört med att vi ändå gjorde en ganska stor förlust förra året.
Samtidigt så har vi ju vuxit, vilket är otroligt roligt.
Vi hoppas att vi landar på runt 50 miljoner i år med då också breakeven.
Börjar ni närma er där för att ni drar ner på forskningen, eller är det mer att ni täcker upp det med topline så att säga?
Nej, vi fortsätter forskningen, men vi har ju samtidigt, om vi under de första åren framförallt hade ett stort R&D-team och ett väldigt litet marketing-team, eftersom vi hade inte så många produkter att marknadsföra, så har det ju nu skiftat och har haft möjligheten att dra ner lite på R&D, men fortsatt att bli behållet fokus på just forskning och utveckling.
Vi utvecklar ju alla våra produkter.
Bara i år så har vi en vetenskaplig artikel publicerad i en global vetenskaplig tidskrift, som då också, alla sådana vetenskapliga artiklar granskas ju av.
Man gör ju en så kallad peer review och den blir bara publicerad då man ser att det håller för en publikation.
Det har vi fått i år och vi har också en, vår andra då patentensökan inlämnad i år.
Så att vi fortsätter absolut med forskningsdelen men den blir ju, den kostar mindre i takt med att vi har en större portfölj och kan göra mer riktade forskningsprojekt helt enkelt.
Och sen så har vi också då fortsatt att gasa på i marknadsföringen.
Och det ser vi ju ger väldigt fina resultat nu.
Framförallt då i Sverige som är den marknad där vi har byggt en varumärkarkännedom under betydligt fler år än vad vi gör internationellt nu.
Ja, och vad är själva affären?
Är det att ni också säljer direkt mot slutkund primärt?
Eller är ni en e-grossist?
Eller licenserar ni ut era formler?
Eller vad är liksom era stora intjäningsmodell?
Vi äger vår egen e-handel och det var...
Är inte det här jävligt krångligt?
Nu säger du ju förlåt, men är det era egna e-handel?
För om ni ska...
Är det inte bara jävligt skumt att börja med att sätta upp en researchdel och sen också driva e-handel?
Det är bara två krångliga delar i en.
Har ni eget lager till och med?
Nej, det har ni i alla fall.
Nej, vi har en 3TL-partner.
Som måste hålla allting kylt då eller?
Ja, jag håller med.
Det är lite galet att vi har ju vårt...
På vårt kontor har vi en kontorsdel och så har vi labbet precis bredvid med bara glasväggar.
Det pågår ju varje dag en massa blandande av kräm.
Hela teamet är ju med och testar och utvärderar och...
Var det meningen från början att ni skulle ha egen e-handel eller tänkte ni att ni skulle vara en grossist liksom?
Nej, vi tänkte från början att vi skulle ha en egen e-handel.
Det är väl det också som är jäkligt kul med det här.
Att vi gör ju allting själva.
Vilket är otroligt roligt och väldigt utmanande helt klart.
Men för oss har det varit väldigt viktigt att ha de här två benen.
Och anledningen till att vi ville köra vår egen e-handel var ju också att vi ser att det finns lite kunskap om huden, vad hudvårdsprodukter egentligen innehåller.
Det finns otroligt mycket myter och sanningar som till stor del kommer från skönhetsindustrin.
För det finns ju en enorm matt i att kunden inte faktiskt riktigt har kunskap om vad som är på riktigt bra för huden.
Då kan man ju sälja saker med att det trollar bort rynkor på tre dagar eller det gör dina ögonfransar 300 procent längre.
Det är svårt för konsumenten att faktiskt förstå.
Vi brukar ju säga att man måste vara nästan en kemist för att förstå hur man läser en ingredienslista på en kosmetisk produkt.
För att ofta innehåller en produkt kanske upp till 60-70 ingredienser.
Och att förstå vad är det i den där produkten som är bra för huden och vad är det som är tillsatt för.
Det är omöjligt för konsumenten att förstå.
Och syftet med vår egen e-handel var ju också att vi behöver jobba så mycket utbildande.
Och då blir ju det en väldigt direkt kanal till våra kunder eller de som kommer in på vår sajt att där utbildar ju vi mycket.
Vi har väldigt mycket artiklar och information om allt från hur den funkar till hur en ingrediens tas fram och så vidare.
Så det har varit en möjlighet att prata direkt till kunden.
Jag tänker två frågor spontant.
Nummer ett så tänker jag, hur gör ni för att inte bli kliniska i er marknadsföring.
För det är väldigt tydligt att ni går igång på själva produkten.
Alltså jag märker ju när du pratar att det är ju såhär, du pratar ju produkt, jag tror första ordet du sa var mikrobiologi eller något sådant.
Men liksom, det är väldigt tydligt att det här är en grej.
Och hur gör man liksom för att inte marknadsföringen ska bli och kännas som en tankrämnsreklam där någon i lab coat står och pratar om.
Utan det ska ändå tilltala målgruppen som inte känner till er.
Och hur kommer det sig att ni är så stora i Sverige att ni inte går mot, jag bara intalar mig att det finns många länder som är mycket mer intresserade av hudvård och som skulle vara mer intresserade av färsk hudvård för att de kanske har större typ smågproblem eller föroreningsproblem än vad Sverige har.
Det känns som att vi, per miljön som vi lever i, kanske inte har samma intresse för det där, utan att jag känner till, jag bara intalar mig att det är så.
Jag skulle säga att vi, för absolut, jag tror att lärdomen vi har gjort under de här åren har ju också varit att vi har ju, vi har nog pratat ett ganska svårt språk i början och vi har tänkt att vi behöver förklara allt, nästan förklara vår forskning och gå in i detaljer kring hur en produkt funkar och ingredienser och absolut så finns det ett väldigt stort intresse lära sig och förstå och så vidare.
Vi har ju, skulle jag säga, ofta en väldigt medveten kund.
Man har en ofta väldigt medveten livsstil och är väldigt noga med vad man stoppar i sig, hur påverkar det min hälsa, vad smörjar jag in mig med och hur påverkar det min hälsa.
Så vi har en väldigt medveten kund.
Men jag tror att det vi har förstått senare är nog att vi kanske inte behöver skriva fem A4-sidor om en produkt och förklara exakt i detalj hur den fungerar och våra forskningsresultat bakom, utan våra kunder litar så mycket på oss att vi behöver egentligen bara förklara vår filosofi och hur vi tänker och att vi alltid är hundra procent transparenta.
Så vi har nog fått jobba med lite att förenkla och inte kanske vara så kliniska som du säger också.
Vi försöker få bort lite den här kliniska känslan, även om många av våra kollegor är med i det content vi tar fram och de har labbrockar, för det är det de jobbar med i labbet.
Men vi försöker samtidigt att visa vilka vi är så att man kommer ändå nära oss.
Vi är ju inget stort team.
För oss har det varit viktigt att komma bort från det kliniska genom att visa vem är vår innovationschef, Ulf.
Han står ju själv i labbet.
Vem är Johanna?
Vem är jag?
Vi visar vilka vi är bakom och vad vi brinner för.
Det har varit väldigt viktigt.
Men sedan för att komma till din andra fråga där, att det här kanske egentligen borde vara större utomlands.
Vi har ju smugit in och festat lite i olika marknader de sista tre åren.
Men Sverige har ändå varit en väldigt viktig marknad bara för att förstå vem är vår kund.
Det har ju också visat sig att det kanske inte är den här väldigt skönhetsintresserade personen, utan det är någon som tänker ganska holistiskt kring sin hälsa och just där medveten att man vill göra smarta val när det kommer till allt i livet.
Och den kunskapen, den har varit ganska viktig att hitta i Sverige för att nu när vi går utomlands så tror vi ändå att det är ungefär den målgruppen som vi ska rikta oss till även nu när vi tassar in i Holland till exempel och Norge och Finland.
Ja men har ni börjat gå utomlands eller är ni precis i uppstarten?
Hur ser de andra marknaderna ut, vad får ni få ge en svar?
För två tre år sedan så bestämde vi oss att göra en satsning i Norge och Tyskland.
Och Norge, vi hade ju ingen stor budget för någon av de här marknaderna utan att vara med att testa sig fram.
Men Norge tog fart från en väldigt låg nivå men så där fortsatte vi att satsa lite i taget och hade så målsättningar att vi skulle växa men vi skulle inte växa.
Det fick inte kosta för mycket.
Men så det har vi byggt under nu tre år.
Och det är nu vår andra största marknad.
Tyskland insåg vi ganska snabbt att med den budget vi hade så blev vi en droppe i havet.
Och det var också mer resurskrävande för att vi var tvungna att ta fram allt material på tyska sajten, digitala annonser på tyska.
Så det blev ett mycket större projekt.
Så det pausade vi efter ett halvår.
Men nu i år så gör vi en ny, vi tar ett omtag.
Satsar på Holland.
Det är ju en marknad som vi också har förstått, men är ofta ganska positivt till skandinaviska varumärken.
Vi kan använda engelska som språk, eftersom man har så hög nivå av kunskaper inom engelska i Holland.
Och vi ser att, vi kan dra lärdom också av flera andra svenska företag som har lyckats där.
Och det är en lite mindre marknad än Tyskland till exempel.
Och så är vi nu inne och tittar lite på Finland.
Hur bygger vi det?
Men det är ju en lärdom att varje marknad är väldigt unik.
Och det är inte en modell som bara funkar överallt.
Utan det tar längre tid än vad vi kanske hade trott från början.
Att hitta det där sättet för varje enskild marknad.
Ja, och varför går man inte in som grossist till redan existerande bolag i andra länder som kanske passar er nisch, eller vad man ska säga.
Det finns med på kartan.
Vi har velat nu titta och lära lite om kunden och lära oss om marknaden.
Och då har vi egentligen, vi satsar ju inte jättestora pengar, utan vi testar oss fram.
Primärt har det varit att gå igång med digital marknadsföring och en del samarbeten med profiler.
Men det är absolut någonting vi tittar på just nu.
Ska vi kanske ha en partner i Holland till exempel som egentligen säljer våra produkter.
För det är ju också utmanande att komma som helt nytt varumärke och det finns ingenstans du kan gå till en fysisk butik och klämma och känna och smörja.
Så det känns viktigt.
Så det finns absolut med i planen.
Hur är det att ha en grundare som är aktiv i bolaget för en enhet som bara kostar pengar?
När du sitter på er månatliga eller årskilliga budgetmöte så kommer hon in där och säger att jag behöver sju miljoner.
Och då säger du att det inte är rimligt, nej men jag vill ha det.
Vi har ju ett fantastiskt orondit-team.
Dels är det Johanna, vår grundare, och sen är det Ulf Åkerström som är vår innovationschef som har jobbat 25 år i branschen och är ju den som tillsammans med Johanna då leder utvecklingen och labbet och forskningen.
Jag skulle säga att båda har ju en...
Du får inte linda in detta.
Hur är det att ha dem på budget?
Nej men det är...
Jag tror att vi har en stark insikt allihopa, att vi behövs allihopa och det bästa resultatet blir när vi enas om till exempel vad ska vi göra inom produktportföljen, vilka nya produkter, var ska vi satsa när det kommer till forskning, kliniska studier.
Så det är faktiskt ingen utmaning.
Och sen så är ju faktiskt båda också väldigt mycket med och driver faktiskt försäljning.
Både Ulf och Johanna är ju med i annonser och de blir intervjuade i tidningar och tv.
Så det är ju en fantastisk tillgång att ha sådana experter i teamet.
Absolut.
Läkartidningen är en volym 37.
Sida 38.
Det är viktigt med huden, det är stort att la.
Nu har vi gjort vår försäljning.
Jag ska inte rentas, men jag tycker ändå det är intressant.
När du kom in på det här företaget, du nämnde förut att ni hade fyra stycken i början där som jobbade bara med research.
Det är ju en ganska stor del av arbetsstyrkan.
Hur har du gjort för att bygga en marknadskultur i det där eller en säljkultur?
Eller nu måste vi börja...
Återigen, jag kan ju inget om detta men jag bara intalar mig att när du börjar prata då till exempel att vi ska rikta annonserna på ett visst sätt eller vi ska hitta det här eller vi behöver utforma förpackningen på ett visst sätt, då kanske det är lätt att om man är ett stort team som jobbar med produkt, att man blir lite beskyddande kring produkterna.
Men det får inte vara någon rolig form på den där utan den ska se proper ut.
Nej men så är det nog.
Jag tror också att där behövdes ju i början där både, dynamiken mellan mig och Johanna första året där, där vi ännu inte hade lanserat några produkter, var ju väldigt, det var ju väldigt viktigt att vi, Johanna är ju som hudforskare såklart fokuserad på att det kan alltid bli bättre, vi kan alltid göra om, vi kan alltid tweka lite så att det blir ännu, ännu bättre.
Medan min roll där, det handlade ju faktiskt om bolagets överlevnad också, att om vi inte kan visa att vi kan ta vår kunskap och göra några produkter och lansera, så kommer vi inte klara oss.
Och där var det ju väldigt viktigt min roll också att kunna komma in och säga att nej men nu är den, vi har tagit fram en fantastisk produkt, även om vi kan jobba två månader till på den, så att nu måste vi nöja oss.
Och sen kan vi göra om, jag menar ta en av våra bästsäljare, den version som är på marknaden nu, det är fjärde versionen.
Så att vi jobbar ju hela tiden på också att förbättra vår existerande kortfölj, men det är ju också samtidigt väldigt viktigt att vi, just att vi kan ha den här dynamiken och också såklart sälja våra produkter.
För att utan att sälja så kan vi ju inte heller forska.
Och det har vi ju pratat väldigt mycket om, att det hänger ihop att kunna bygga ett bolag som också nu börjar röra sig mot lönsamhet.
Det är ju faktiskt väldigt, väldigt viktigt för till sjuven och sist så vill vi ju alla, oavsett om vi är hudforskare eller om jag som vd, vi vill ju faktiskt att fler ska få bättre hudhälsa och vi vill att fler ska kunna använda våra fantastiska produkter.
För det är ju allting kretsat kring produkten igen.
Du sa det, det var det första jag började prata om, men det är fortfarande det allra viktigaste för oss.
Så det är skulle jag säga den viktigaste anledningen till att vi har vuxit också för att vi har så glada nöjda kunder och de får så mycket hjälp med sin hudhälsa och fina resultat och om vi inte tänker kommersiellt också så är det ju många som faktiskt inte fått tillgång till Skinhorms produkter.
Så det har varit en väldigt viktig dynamik där.
När du tar in folk nu som ska in i bolaget, är det liksom en säljkort då?
Hur mycket måste man vara in i hudvård för att komma in?
Måste man brinna för hudvård?
Man måste tycka att hudvård är kul.
Och sen så det vi gör, det tar ju tid att förstå.
Vi är ju väldigt annorlunda där.
Det är inte alltid så enkelt att förklara våra produkter, eller vårt koncept eller vår filosofi.
De flesta som också kanske har börjat i vårt marknadsteam hade nog förmodligen aldrig hört talas om hudens mikrobiom innan de började.
Och precis som jag då, när jag började prata med Johanna för sex år sen, hade nog inte heller funderat på vad som är i hudvårdsprodukter.
Men det är just det där att när man väl börjar tänka och får en förståelse och lär sig, då är det väldigt svårt också att tänka sig att använda någonting annat.
Och det är det jag ser när vi bygger teamet nu och det kommer in personer som kanske inte har jobbat specifikt med hudvård innan, men har en kompetens som vi vill och driv som vi vill, så lär man sig väldigt snabbt och många också får de här insikten att det här är verkligen det bästa.
Och då blir det också lättare att ta till sig och prata om det och tolka det beroende på vilken roll man har i teamet.
Men finns det inte, för vad är det som är, och jag menar frågan på ett kärleksfullt sätt, men vad är det, det finns väl annan färsk hudvård, eller det finns väl hudvård som också är avskalad, om jag förstår rätt, som liksom inte innehåller dåliga.
Vad är det som verkligen sticker ut här, vad är det som ni forskar på?
Jag tänkte att jag lägger det i slutet av programmet, så att folk som verkligen, hehehehe, bara skiter i huvudet.
Så att folk som nördar ner sig kan lyssna.
Vad är det ni verkligen lägger forskningen på?
Vad vi menar med färsk hudvård är ganska många olika parametrar.
Det man behöver komma ihåg.
Ja, då kan vi dra det inom.
Kan vi försöka dra det under två minuter?
Jag lovar.
Ja, det handlar om att sätta hudens bästa först.
Men genom att ha den ambitionen att aldrig kompromissa med vad som är i produkten för hudens skull, så har vi kommit fram till att det enda sättet att göra den bästa hudvården på, det är att göra färsk hudvård.
Och vad menas då med det?
Dels så utersluter vi alla former av tillsatser.
I en vanlig produkt kan uppemot 40-50% av ingredienslistan faktiskt handla om tillsatser som inte är där för hudens skull.
Så vi tar bort allt sånt.
Så du får egentligen 700% ingredienser som din hud behöver.
Nummer två är att genom att ta bort alla tillsatser och ha kortare hållbarhet så kräver det också kylförvaring.
Precis som dina färskvaror som du stoppar in i kylen utan att förmodligen reflektera över varför så kräver en del av våra produkter kylförvaring just för att vi skippar alla tillsatser.
Men det fina med det är också att kylförvaringen gör att vi kan bibehålla och garantera effekten av väldigt många ingredienser som har vetenskapligt bevisad effekt men som faktiskt är väldigt känsliga för rumstemperatur och som också kan degradera och tappa i effekt över tid.
Så vi har ju också kortare hållbarhet på våra produkter.
Det är tolv månader och vi är ju också bland de enda i världen skulle jag vilja säga som faktiskt skriver ut produktionsdatum.
Och den transparensen, det är någonting som vi väldigt gärna vill inspirera vår bransch till att ta till sig.
För att när du köper en hudborgsprodukt eller en annan konsumentisk produkt så har du faktiskt ingen aning om oftast när den tillverkades.
Den kan ju ha stått på ett lager två år innan den hamnar hemma hos dig.
Och sen så handlar det också om det här då med hudens mikrobiom.
Det är därför vi heter Skinom.
Hudens mikrobiom har visat sig då, man har ju forskat på det här i ungefär bara tio år, att det är otroligt viktigt för att vårt hud ska må glada.
Vi behöver leva i symbios med våra goda bakterier.
Vanligt traditionell hudvård och andra skönhetsprodukter, det kan faktiskt störa huden.
Så just att fokusera på mikrobiomvänlig hudvård och ta sådana ingredienser som stöttar ditt naturliga system, det har varit väldigt, väldigt viktigt.
Och en sista grej är också att vi tittar väldigt mycket på vad tillverkar din hud själv för substanser?
För att din hud tillverkar ju inte själv mandelolja eller rosenextrakt.
Och vi tittar ju väldigt mycket på vad är kompositionen av fett och mineraler och salter som din egen hud tillverkar?
För det är det vi vill tillsätta då för att stötta återigen hudens naturliga system.
För att förklara det här, det tar ju lite tid.
Men vi brukar då säga att färsk hudvård handlar om kylförvarig för att skippa konsumeringsmedel och bevara effekten.
Och att vi bara har ingredienser i produkten som hjälper huden till bättre hälsa.
Ja fan det är en lång säljtids, men jag fattar, det är nog under två minuter.
Det känns som fyra.
Exakt, exakt.
Men det är lite det här som vi, det här skulle jag vilja säga är nog vår största utmottning.
Att som konsument idag så vet man kanske inte riktigt, eller funderar inte.
Och vi vill ju inte säga att någon är dum, utan snarare, vi vill utmana vår egen bransch.
Hur mycket, hur mycket, hur mycket liksom har du ångest över att du inte får vara lite halvdrygig.
Alltså, om jag hade, hade jag jobbat och ser, då hade ju min första kampanj varit typ, när tillverkades din produkt?
Och så är det hela, hela liksom, sälj pitchen att folk ska kolla på sin produkt och så finns det inget.
Då är det så här, den har ju stått där i åtta år, du fattar det va.
Alltså det är väl ganska roligt att komma från en sådan lite underdog, aggressiv, är det inte bara lite tröttsamt att jobba med folk som är pråpra?
Ja, vi har försökt sticka ut och vi försöker få in det där budskapet här och där.
Hur stack ni ut?
Vad var er, vad var er, vad ska man säga, mest utstickande kampanj?
Men det är en av våra annonser, digitala annonser, det har egentligen bara varit en bild där vi skriver, hej hudvårdsindustrin, varför använder ni fortfarande ämnen som PFAS, misstänkt hormonstörande ämnen, konserveringsmedel, parfymer i era krämer, när ni faktiskt vet att det inte är det bästa för huden?
Taggade ni folk i branschen som jobbar inom de bolagen eller företagen som ni stör är på mest?
Det borde vi kanske ha gjort, så det är ett bra fix.
Jag tror att vi har tittat till exempel på, jag menar till Oakley, som har gjort en fantastisk resa, bara underdogen.
Jag tror att vi skulle kunna göra lite mer av det.
Det är lite klurigt det där, man vill inte skuldlägga någon, man vill inspirera och förklara vad vi gör.
Men samtidigt så tror jag att vi behöver kanske utmana lite mer, helt klart.
Jag förstår.
Jag vet att du jobbar med Jakob Wibon Westerberg, som har den här andra podden vi brukar driga oss mot varandra med, den som har best podd och sånt där.
Men han är ju väldigt proper som människa.
Detta är ultra internt, alla ni andra kan stänga av nu.
Men liksom, är han så där proper och trevlig även i verkligheten eller slappnar han av ibland?
Kommer han någonsin till jobbet i mjukisk kläder?
Jag har nog aldrig sett honom i mjukisk kläder ska jag säga.
Han är ganska proper.
Ibland kanske lite längre skägg och lite längre hår, men annars är han väldigt proper.
Är det han som håller tillbaks era reklamkampanjer?
Är det han som gör att ni inte är roliga?
Nej då, han är väldigt rolig.
Vi har ju haft ett fantastiskt samarbete.
Vi har jobbat ihop i ett och ett halvt år nu.
Han är ju en...
Du behöver inte säga något snällt, vi klipper det här.
Vi stoppar det här.
Lydia, stort stort tack för att du var med.
Uppenbart låter det som att du hamnat på rätt plats och att du gillar en produkt.
Det har nog alltid varit så tydligt i ett poddavsnitt någonsin.
Stort tack för att du var med.
Tack för att jag fick vara med.
Ja, jag förstår.
Du tappar mig redan i första startmeningen.
Vad betyder Microbangnum?